e aí a gente melhorar tudo vocês sabem o
quanto mais idiota mais engraçados e
porque todo mundo gosta de ver as
pessoas terão de ver os amigos cair de
ver alguém levou um tombo tem um canal
no youtube que faz isso aí os caras
nunca lá fenice seu estilo de 1 o que
chama de um alternativo tudo aquilo que
a gente gosta de ver pra ficar nu depois
o farei
é massa clique aqui para conhecer ou a
fênix e se colocam dois dias por semana
e tem um bocado de quadro legal lá então
se escreve o que quer mesmo tempo os
cursos é comer eu culpo os cursos teve
coquetel para ele o estava sujo pra
[ __ ] de pele g é de um jeito
a então nessa semana o nosso canal
chegou a 100 mil inscritos já que lopes
de uma coisa pra vocês se você faz parte
desse 100 inscritos e você tem sempre
presente toda quarto todo o sábado da
ufpi para se manifestar não gostei eu e
você eu quero ver os inscritos canal não
só conhecer inscrito inscrito é gente
pra [ __ ] e estou muito feliz a idéia
de quando comecei a fazer vídeo no
youtube eu já sonhava muito tem uma
coisa de destaque em algo que eu pudesse
jogar as minhas ideias para a galera
curtir a galera compartilhar deu muito
certo eu to muito feliz eu queria
agradecer primeiramente a vocês porque
esse número só é possível graças a vocês
pois quando algumas perguntas que a
galera fez sobre o teu 100 inscritos à
luciano certo neste turno você pensar
que faria tanto sucesso como hoje ainda
tem muito mais com viram seus vídeos
nunca pensei em parar pois tem gente que
acredita nos seus vídeos parabéns por
tudo e obrigado também muito obrigado
pelo carinho luciano bom se eu pensava
que teria sucesso como hoje pensava isso
não é uma forma robusta de falar ah eu
já sabia que ia fazer sucesso na geral
que não mais aqui quando você tem um
sonho para você entrar nele é para
arregaçar mesmo você quer comprar um
carro aí você trabalha sei lá de
servente pedreiro que já pagou o carro
fosse meu novo trabalho há sete anos
comprar toda a ficar truncada existentes
mesmo para kelly lima aquele é o sonho
do carro e vai trabalhar 17 anos até
comprar o carro e assim sou eu e quem é
meu fã de verdade sabe que eu gosto no
facebook que eu terminaria o ano com 100
mil inscritos e também com mais provar
isso sr dias perguntou alguma vez você
já pensou em desistir muitas vezes às
vezes se faz tanta você produz tanto se
dá o melhor de si a galera 11 curtir ano
compartilha você fica pouco vou parar de
sair outra vez que votaria pará foi na
exclusão meu canal pra quem não sabe o
canal antes desde 1 30 mil inscritos e
um belo dia festa' no canal e comecei a
receber um monte de mensagem de celular
matzá pulo no twitter cara do canal
próprio canal tentar entrar no canal
tinha programa não tinha sido excluído e
ainda não consegui me recuperar mas ele
criou o canal como esse jogar video tô
aqui com mais 100 mil inscritos para
calar a boca de muita fila da [ __ ] falou
alex atala perguntou quando as pessoas
começaram a se reconhecer na rua por
causa dos seus vídeos ou sua fama no
meio para todos nós aqui de alagoas
um beijo pra todo mundo legal alagoas eu
comecei a ser reconhecido na rua depois
de quando eu passei de uns 30 mil
inscritos e mora em teresina na cidade e
se tão grande então as pessoas costumam
nos mesmos lugares foi que o flamengo
jogará é shopping de carbono e tal e aí
quando eu vou a platéia acontece muito a
galera me conhecer me tira foto e tal
liga para a irmã vai conversar liga para
mãe tudo começa amanhã a grazi rl perto
como os eficientes em todos esses fãs em
todos os estados
eu me sinto muito feliz para mim fico
muito feliz é um dos fatos que me deixa
mais feliz é saber que por enquanto tem
gente do piauí que mora em miami tem
gente do brasileiro que mora em portugal
tem vindo de santa catarina do mato
grosso de de tonga só não dar um cara
que assistir os vídeos eu fico muito
feliz que era quando a coisa chega assim
pra muita gente quer dizer que isso é
uma coisa boa eu gosto dessa maravilha
mas não minha casa então é isso fico
feliz pagar a nf e pega o macaé que não
vai dar para responder todas seria muito
agradecer a você que assiste aos vídeos
cara você está aqui toda quarta e todos
os sábados para um vídeo novo hoje é
terça-feira ninguém tá nem esperando que
lobos mas é isso aqui é uma pessoa
normal amanhã já vai ter outro vídeo
diferente você está sempre aqui na
quarta e no sábado ficando gostei
comentando compartilhando muito obrigado
eu queria também agradecer à rua 06 meu
fã clubes que têm espalhado pelo brasil
e é tem muita gente que gosta de mim
embora tal ponto de criar uma página e
administrar ela para ficar me ajudando a
a divulgar os vídeos e isso é muito bom
que eu queria muito agradecer fazendo
winston humor do hino sou fã do insumo
no ne e outros têm muitas
não é eu não falei não é porque eu acho
mais importante não é porque se eu falar
todos aí mas muito obrigado a vocês
mesmo obrigado a ev brigado anat
obrigado o gabela e isso obrigado a
tomar milan bem pegado muito todas as
pessoas querem mexer nos défices muito
obrigado agradeceu como eu sempre
agradeço a mariana bordignon que foi a
menina que emprestavam número próprio de
fazemos nos primeiros vídeos primeiros -
os primeiros muito obrigado muito
obrigado pela câmera do hubble gente é
muito projeto novo canal era certo muito
novidade do carnaval este ano é nunca
vou parar de fazer log nunca parar de
fazer paródia nunca vou parar de fazer
nada tudo chegar à final é sempre a
acrescentar nada pra tirar eu tenho uma
novidade muito boa eu tô querendo ainda
para este mês se der certo pé da serra
só depressa novidade vai precisar
comprar uma câmera nova né porque é uma
coisa que necessita de uma imagem
diferente tal soja o sport está me
ajudando esses custos e se vocês me
ajudarem junto com ela eu vou conseguir
cara eu vou conseguir comprar a câmera
ainda essa semana aqui em baixo na
descrição do vídeo tem assim loja o
sport quando sua equipe neste link a
loja sabe que você foi no site da loja
por causa do meu ver então você já tá me
ajudando então me ajuda a comprar esse
câmera clique neste link para o site la
em várias tem várias roupas legais
aspecto negativo que gosta de alguma
coisa lá pra você e sei como sempre eu
tô sempre ajudando a uma pessoa que tá
querendo fazer alguma coisa alguma
página que ajuda a gente e necessitada
alguém que precisa ganhar uma promoção
alguma coisa e dessa vez temos um leque
de teresina que estão querendo ganhar
uma promoção pra poder ir para são paulo
gravar um cd e isso os caras com ele
nessas promoções preciso de
visualizações em um vídeo então queria
pedir para vocês que gritassem nesse
vídeo aqui e repito neste vídeo você vai
abrir o virtus carlos sainz senhora
vamos dar então é isso aí tá
estou muito feliz em inscritos que é um
número muito grande se você faz parte
desse 100 inscritos você está aqui toda
quarta e todos saibam se você está
compartilhando você está curtindo falou
por favor clique aqui não gostei eu
quero ver a minha galera eu quero ver
100 inscritos
eu quero ver a atitude de vocês o meu
carro eu quero ver vocês presente aqui
então sei lá deixou uma mensagem e isso
foi um sonho pra mim é um sonho
realizado se você tem algum sonho
comenta embaixo e não é só isso você não
tá escrito esse canal ainda é só clicar
aqui e inscrever se e muito obrigado
muito obrigado